[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui deux
grands malades de musique michka assayas
et benoît duteurtre qui publie chez
buchet chastel avec alexandre fillon
remède musicaux de mozart à clara
luciani 200 musique pour tous les
moments de la vie
alors que faut-il écouter quand on est
triste quand on a la flemme quand on est
confiné quand on a envie de tout
détruire ou quand on veut arriver à
l'orgasme il y en a 300 pages on va y
passer toute l'émission histoire de
vérifier par nous-mêmes en écoutant
leurs meilleures propositions mais avant
d'écouter de la musique commençons par
des images celles que vous avez choisie
pour illustrer notre époque michka
assayas
on va regarder tout de suite la vôtre
c'est des cons c'était y'a pas longtemps
c'est en bulgarie ce sont des
des fonctionnaires qui se rendent chez
un citoyen qui est confiné pour le faire
voter aux élections présidentielle et
législatives je trouvais que c'était
l'image extérieure parce qu'elle
ressemble à un film de science fiction
qui auraient pu être tournées
effectivement dans un pays de l'est sur
les années 80 parce qu'on voit en effet
ses immeubles
oui exactement et je me suis dit mais
non c'est la réalité c'est notre réalité
on vit là dedans et voilà enfin que
personne n'a eu le mauvais goût de venir
nous faire voter domicile quand on nous
a fait sortir nous
non mais ça peut plus produire
benoît duteurtre
la vôtre est un petit peu plus anciennes
cc je le dis pour les plus jeunes qui
dort garde c'est luis maria dos c'est
luis mariano dans le chanteur de mexico
au châtelet le chanteur de mexico de
francis le belge francis lopez non mais
je j'ai choisi simplement d'abord est-ce
qu'on est à la fin de l'année qu'on peut
chercher quelque chose en lien avec la
musique et vous savez que le châtelet a
été alors on va le voir puisque vous
avez la moto aussi du théâtre du
châtelet a été pendant des générations
et pour des générations le luron
n'allait se soigner de toute sa
tristesse et mélancolie en regardant des
spectacles de divertissement musical
extraordinaire c'était vraiment le lieu
on appelle les opm ça des opérettes mais
aussi plus récemment par exemple
et comédies musicales américaines vont
était monté en quantité avec beaucoup de
succès c'était vraiment le théâtre du
divertissement musical et puis il se
trouve que ces dernières années la
mairie de paris l'a transformé en
théâtre sociétal avec une programmation
qui vous invite à réfléchir sur les
questions de genre les discriminations
etc le divertissement musical a
quasiment disparu au profit du spectacle
très très sérieux un peu dans le genre
de ce qui se passe en face vous savez au
théâtre de la ville et ça a été un tel
échec que fort heureusement la
directrice anglaise très branché qui
avait lancé cette programmation a fini
par être éjecté et enfin cet hiver est
un spectacle qui s'appelle colporteurs à
paris retour du divertissement musical
au china co est porteur alors
colporteurs le grand compositeur de
multi de comédies musicales américaines
et par une troupe formidable qui
s'appelle les frivolités parisienne donc
c'est voilà le châtelet renouer avec son
histoire et je trouve ça très bien que
la ville de paris finissent par admettre
que c'est pas forcément seulement
ringard et débile d'aller voir des
grands divertissements musicaux parce
que ça fait du bien alors je vous
présente tous les vices cas ça y est
vous êtes journaliste musical écrivain
rock critic vous avez débuté à rock'n
folk et aux inrockuptibles on vous doit
entre autres un dictionnaire du rock en
trois volumes aux éditions robert
laffont et c'est vous qui animé sur
france inter une émission musicale
baptisée very good trip
benoît duteurtre vous êtes romancier
vous êtes fait connaître il ya plus de
30 ans maintenant avec tout doit
disparaître
vous êtes vous aussi critique musical et
votre requiem pour une avant garde en 95
vous avait valu les foudres de pierre
boulez et de ses thuriféraires vous
c'est sur france musique que vous a dit
mais écoutez moi benoît une émission sur
la chanson et le père est vous publiez
donc tous les deux avec alexandre fillon
remède musicaux chez buchet chastel de
mozart à clara luciani 200 musique pour
tous les moments de la vie vous avez
fait un travail de ce qu'on appelle à
hollywood un musique planeur ce sont ces
gens qui cherchent le bon morceau à
coller sur telle ou telle scène du film
vous avez fait la même chose mais
surtout les modeler de notre existence
vous pensez vraiment que la musique est
un remède pour moi c'est le remède
absolu donc
après les applications spécifiques sont
toujours discutable on essayait d'en
trouver enfin lewis
et moi écouter ya pas un chagrin de la
vie qui n'ait été sinon réparer du moins
atténuer dans la musique mais benoît
duteurtre je pense que la musique est
par essence un remède contre eux je
dirais la monotonie et l'ennui de l'avim
a commencé à dévorer de la musique quand
j'étais adolescent tout d'un coup le
temps morne se teinter de couleurs de
personnages d'énergie de rythme la vie
serait tellement rasoir sans musique
effectivement parce que il ne se passe
rien et donc pour moi c'est vraiment le
remède voilà qui donne de la couleur au
temps qui qui qui qui nous divertit et
en plus avec ce mystère quand même
particulier de la musique qui fait
qu'ils se livraient très fantaisiste
mais un tout petit peu sérieuses et que
la musique évidemment joue à la fois sur
l'esprit et sur le physique il ya quand
même une chose dans les ondes musicales
qui est purement sensuelle donc on peut
ne pas exclure que la musique que c'est
aussi avoir un effet de remettre presque
physiologique en même temps qu'elle est
un remède à nos chats gras et la gestion
à la question s'est ennuyé c est ce que
quand on est triste est ce qu'on doit
écouter de la musique triste ou est-ce
qu'on doit écouter de la musique gaie
par exemple évidemment pour la tristesse
vous proposez chopin on va écouter on va
écouter beaucoup de musique donc
allons-y et puis n'hésitons pas à parler
sur la musique aussi parce que
c'est de la télé c'est pas de la radio
et
donc allons-y pour chopin
début du
du nocturne en la bémol j'ai pas choisi
tristesse extrême csbf tristesse c'est
trop rabâcher trop repris par la variété
et cetera la ceara aussi mais c'est vrai
que je sais pas si je suis riche je
pense à chaque page écoute du chopin
c'est que ça me sort de la tristesse ou
est elle accuse au contraire parce que
c'est une tristesse voluptueuse s'il ya
une telle organisation de l'harmonie une
telle richesse des tales frottement une
telle jubilation ci à faire des trade
piano très riche comme ça que la
sonorité qui exprime la tristesse et en
même temps quelque chose qui va alors là
presque physiquement et moralement où
nous nous mettrons en extase donc c'est
ça tout le paradoxe de la tristesse on
lui dit que c'est que la tristesse en
musique elle est extatique quand elle
est bien faite du moins avoir un bon
compositeur comme chopin s'échappe pas
michka assayas j'imagine que ça vient de
vous comme vous proposer tout match
wayne la chanson paul mccartney pour
lutter contre le découragement par
exemple on va l'écouter 1to motion
personnellement je n'y aurait pas de
macartney avait continué de faire des
chansons après les beatles à bord mais
allons-y pour tout match wayne ben sékou
tcc c'est une chose
comme un peu tout et savoir m
oui oui
[Musique]
tu auras
[Applaudissements]
oui mais ce qui s'est en fait il
s'adresse à quelqu'un qui en fait pour
être lui-même disait tu avais l'habitude
de cacher ta ta ta ta tristesse et vous
font il dit y a pas de mal à pleurer à
conduire il ya un moment donné dans la
vie où
on éprouve une telle peine une enfin
comment dire quelque chose de petit bout
qui vous plaisent tellement sur les
époux ya tellement de pluie ya tellement
nuages dans la vie qu' il faut que ça
sorte que ce soit dit et il le dit avec
beaucoup de tendresse il le dit avec une
sorte de de presse de sagesse reste
rasséréné mais sans que ce soit pour
autant
du détachement je ne sais pas comment
vous expliquez ça c'est le miracle de la
musique c'est son mystère c'est qu'il
parle d'un sentiment extrêmement
plombant et en même temps il a fait
quelque chose d'extrêmement léger qui
vous qui vous arrache l'attraction
terrestre c'est presque de l'opérette
je dirais pas ça comme ça parce que
c'est pas une référence pour moi on
parlait de ray ventura tout à l'heure
vraiment avoir des missions mais yahia
et si vous voulez ya cette élégance de
paul mccartney qui consiste en effet de
ne pas être dans l'emphase dans la
gravité quand il parle de choses tristes
alors aux enfants un chien et un autre
morceau que vous proposez celui de
george thorogood oui à armes égales
jones thorogood une chanson de plus de 8
minutes oui
écoutons de la gare d'eau oui oui un peu
[Musique]
mon père
c'était un très jeune bluesman blanc
d'un tout petit et américains devant la
côte est le delaware et je l'avais vu
sur scène il avait un câble de 50 mètres
de l'eau qui le reliait à son emprise
qui fait qu'il descendait à la scène il
allait d'histoire boire des verres
o'barry repartait et jouets c'est selon
au milieu des gens c'était comme une
espèce de fête sauvage qui avait quelque
chose il a en fait il est il explique un
patron de bar tous les minuit alors si
c'est une chanson très saine ne tenez au
coeur lutter contre le découragement à
un scotch un bourbon ou une bière voilà
c'est sa commande et moi j'ai imaginé
que c'est en fait cette chanson en fait
pourquoi j'en parle dans ce livre parce
que c'est lié pour moi à une espèce de
délivrance des états désespérant vous
savez comme chez part on est bloqué en
pleine tempête de neige la voiture
démarre plus sur le parking
vous ajourd'hui et vous ça vous savez
plus quoi faire et vous écoutez ça et on
fond vous dit de toute façon j'ai boire
deux trois coups à la buvette et ça va
ça va repartir forcément va je veux dire
la vie va continuer je vais surmonter
cet épisode d désespérant parce que ça
on a envie de se flinguer parfois dans
des situations pareilles six minutes
il ya le temps d'entrer dans cette
espèce de 800
blessés c'est le blues le blues et bien
c'est un très bel exemple le blues c'est
les bleus c'est les bleus à l'âme mais
c'est une chose qu'il musique qui peut
justement vous rendre extrêmement joyeux
contre l'absence de volonté je pense que
c'est vous benoît duteurtre qui
recommandait la cinquième de beethoven
oui alors la cinquième devant tout le
monde la connaît c'est bon on peut quand
même en écouter un petit peu mais c'est
important parce que ce motif
justement
du début qui est repris indéfiniment
après c'est justement l'illustration
même de ce génie de ben et orgue qui
dans toute la vie et toute l'oeuvre est
une question de construction par la
volonté c'est à dire que c'est quelqu'un
qui d'abord suivi des épreuves
extraordinaire et qui va vouloir dans
toute sa vie exprimée une espèce de joie
supérieur par l'explosion sa volonté
mais dans sa musique même il part de
petits motifs extrêmement simple et très
singuliers comme ça et ils les agents
centre à l'infini les développe pour
construire une espèce de cathédrales
extraordinaire donc ne suis pas si vous
voulez les codes de la musique pré
existante mais construit par sa seule
volonté une espèce de grand édifié à
partir de quelques petits fragments
comme sens de la volonté d'ailleurs dans
la seine qui a toujours une énergie
extraordinaire chez beethoven qui le
pape et il peut développer à l'infini
comme ça un petit motif avec une énergie
rythmique dans des couleurs les plus
différentes ils perdent peu de choses il
trouve une idée et il l'a construit la
transforme en cathédrale
dans votre livre que j'ai trouvé ça
également parce qu'il ya aussi quelques
astuces en matière de santé il paraît
que c'est bon pour le corps un pur quand
on a un cancer du sein il ya un certain
nombre de remèdes comme savons qu'ils
sont quand même très très discutée là on
passe dans lance de ce qu'on appelle la
musicothérapie il semblerait aussi que
le violon soit bon pour lutter contre
l'épilepsie les quatuors à cordes de
beethoven contre l'hystérie il ya eu des
expériences de fait par des groupes de
médecins vous avez un peu dans l'époque
charcot tout ça avec tout le monde
autour d'un patient et que et mozart
remonterait les points de qi est
également oui enfin c'est comme ça
pendant un quart d'heure on a un peu
plus de 2.2 cuisse et augmenterait notre
sous-région spéciale voilà mais il ya un
versement d'ailleurs j'en parle aussi
donc par des citations dans le livre
notamment de nietzsche il considère
aussi que de musique qui rendent malade
un honneur
malade est d'abord faut lutter contre la
flemme chèque à vos échecs d'otis
redding ah oui mais ça ça alors ça
effectivement moi c'est la chanson pour
laquelle je découvert au québec avec une
reprise de sam cooke qui est vraiment
l'inventeur de la musique soul alors
chez otis redding qui au fond est la
matrice de bob marley parce que quand on
y ait oud et maniérisme se retrouve chez
marc les
libyens
une sonic permanente contre
l'avachissement stars contre le
désespoir dire que l'asie même de
testing est une sorte d'explosion des
deux de vitalité très court très court
il est mort avait eu des morts à 27 28
ans dans un accent de des avions en face
et c'était le chanteur soul le plus
électrifiant alors évidemment il y avait
cette matrice qui était dans le gospel
puisque c'est là la seule la version
profane de la musique sacrée 1 celle des
églises voilà du sud des états unis
entre autres est chez lui il y avait à
la fois je dirais la joie et la joie la
capsule désespoir le plus absolu et je
pense que la joie n'aurait pas la même
énergie la même vitalité la même force
s'il n'y avait pas quelque chose de
presque moody en lui
cci afin beau maudit c'est peut-être oui
je sais pas comment dire mais quelque
chose en effet de désespérer
certainement contre l'insomnie dieu sait
s'il ya des gens qui souffrent
d'insomnie vous proposez une berceuse
basque mais de forêt attention c'est une
perceuse de gabriel fauré mais
normalement ça marche
je suis pas sûr que ça marche parce que
c'est tellement mieux quand on commence
à l'écouté moi j'ai pas envie de dormir
avec l'om j'ai voulu mettre en ruine
valeur le fait que le répertoire de
berceuses et pas seulement les petites
chansons que je chante la maman au bord
du lit c'est vraiment
sans dormir et la berceuse de chopin et
sublime la verseuse de forêt par un
temps là est une merveille pour violon
et piano pendant trop rarement mais je
cite aussi les berceuses pygmées qui
sont extraordinaires je cite aussi
les conditions de benoît milan ac a fait
déverser il est sifflé du yodel vous
savez oui mais alors si je peux me
permettre quand on dit d'une musique et
des soporifiques ce n'est pas
nécessairement un compliment c'est pour
ça que je dis oui voila c est dangereux
non
ça vous berce dans louis vous berce dans
le jeu du livre il ya quand même le fait
de donner des remèdes plus ou moins
sérieux il ya aussi simplement de partir
d'une idée comme celle de la berceuse
pour faire découvrir des musiques qu'on
aime bien
c'est qu'à la fin paul mccartney dont on
parlait tout à l'heure chantal lasbats
te sens comme une berceuse et c est ça
nous endort pas non au contraire c'est
le salvador non plus oui oui mes
chansons et la berceuse ça pourrait être
et vous l'avez mis sous sous sous le
sous l'intitulé de l' envie de tout
détruire oui c'est cela oui
xb
effectivement et ça roule à l'époque ça
a fait du bruit abbas a en fait encore
aujourd'hui 4 a publié ça
c'est une erreur de dessin animé c'est
vraiment et c'est l'idée va taper le
mort me taper sur la tête du board est
une batte de baseball d'autres sont
blessés vraiment il en dit vous savez
comme dans ses dessins animés
complètement cinglé tom et jerry cette
affaire c'est vraiment quelqu'un vous
contraint quelque chose vous rend fou
vous avez envie de effectivement de
poursuivre de tout de tout cacher
l'occurrence a ainsi plutôt à le
poursuivre et à tout casser complètement
celle de calme l'annoncé par m contre
tout casser c'est une sorte de palier
titre royal était si quand vous écoutez
ça en fait votre désir en effet de
d'exterminer vos ennemis de tuer enfin
tout ce qui vit tout ce qui vous
puisqu'il vous rend fou et
exercer
correctement en quelques minutes
j'aimerais qu'on voit les quatre belles
fait d'intellectuels
dont ils sont tous morts les photos très
tardive il y avait des remplaçantes
aiderait là ils ont dû effectivement le
poggio et ramon et ils étaient déjà plus
là waouh il était mort oui c'était pire
que m6 five
survivants ah oui j'allais vraiment bien
la pluie alors là on est en plein punk
un musique qui déborde d'énergie oui
d'ailleurs ne se voulait que de
l'énergie purin quasiment oui apple
avait aussi quand même quelque chose de
provocateur et de destruction des
structures aussi en flandre n était pas
l aider pas simplement sais pas c'était
pas du comme de métal ou le hard rock
des différents ils sont tous morts vous
traitez de la peur de la mort dans ce
livre évidemment parce qu'elle nous
étreint assez régulièrement vous
conseillez encore du forez d'ailleurs
oui le requiem mais écoutons si on veut
quelques notes de du dernier mouvement
jeunesse partie grâce à la convention
[Musique]
ce qui est beau dans requiem de fauré ce
qui nous emmène vraiment au paradis
c'est à dire que c'est son titre
d'ailleurs oui vous avez des idées ça
c'est ce morceau in paradisio la fin du
réel mais les grands requiem classique
de verdi de mozart même de brahms et
plus des requiem de sur la mort sur la
peur de la mort la terreur de la mort de
contrer la mort même si c'est par le
prisme religieux s'est pas complètement
négatif mais il ya quand même quelque
chose de sombre et de théâtral efforts
et lui il nous transporte dans les
limbes et il me laisse entendre que
c'est quand même merveilleux de sela au
planned vrai faux bond puisque les tice
que nous permet de gérer j'écoutais
intégralement ci au jt était malade dans
les foyers de mozart dans mon lit et
javidan ça comme ça et j'ai écouté et
j'ai eu le sentiment de renaître la
salle renaissance parce que c'est que
soit une masse liturgique en face à ces
voix là mais il ya quelque chose c'est
peut-être la vie après la mort je ne
sais pas es tu prête ses traits et là je
me préparais mes jeux gt gt je puis
voilà je suis mort mais je renais
c'était merveilleux mais vraiment le
shérif j'avais fini en plus celui de
forêt c'est le plus planants de tous
quoi c'est vraiment c'est de la pure
extasiait fine page sombre quasiment
dans le web de forêt on se laisse voilà
se laisse bercer mais bien aussi
la musique était extatique oui oui
pardon moi j'aime bien les musiques
extatique c'est pour ça que j'aime aussi
oui la musique répétitive ou les très
longues chose de messiaen
recommandé steve reich oui
peu connu parce que pendant très
longtemps on était obligé d'écouter
boulez on avait l'interdiction enfance
d'écouter ce tirage depuis on a le droit
d'aller et ça vous le conseillez quand
on n'arrive pas à se concentrer tout à
coup des côtés du steve reich et c'est
vrai on va remonter un peu le son pour
voir à quel point on peut se concentrer
plus facilement avec ça
ça c'est le début de musique pour 18
musiciens qui est le chef-d'oeuvre de
steve reich un ça dure une heure et
c'est sur un seul accord quasiment mais
les figures musicales se transforme
c'est très nuancées comme totalement
c'est infini glace moi j'ai encore mieux
avec une petite cigarette de cannabis en
plus un formidable mais en cédant
at-elle 5 et une loi contre l'apologie
de
ces presque tous les pays voisins le
sont en passe de légaliser comme en
france est interdit donc c'est une
musique totalement planante v qui comme
c'est toujours la même chose eh ben on
peut on peut travailler réfléchir dessus
on est on n'est pas distrait d'une
certaine façon par des éléments bruts
taux qui arrive on est simplement porter
dans une espèce de
deux permanences du temps et je pense
que c'est fait il faut que ce serait bon
pour la concentration nous avait
d'ailleurs il ya un lien avec le rock ce
qui est terry riley qui a été un grand
vabre en planant répétitif qui a
beaucoup influencé
quantité de musiciens de rock
de prendre l'introduction de balles
réelles et des coûts d'un who's next c
'est une sorte de couper coller enfin
deux dernières années mais cela dit moi
je me rappelle avoir assisté à des
concerts de musique planante dans autour
de ma lointaine adolescence d'ailleurs
on l'a oublié mais les gens étaient
couchés quand il les écoute il est signé
avec les conseils de pink floyd mais
tout à fait espère que vraiment c'est
quand le punk est arrivé que les gens se
sont mis à écouter des concerts doubi
relevé jeux sont relevés mais les vrais
d'ailleurs que le funk et des contres
pink floyd et les équipements les gens
ne dansait pas il puisse coucher et je
dirais lycées blaise couche mm déb était
d'aider leurs manteaux ils faisaient ils
se livraient certaines activités voilà
que la morale réprouve en particulier
quant à jo rin dream a joué à la
cathédrale de reims maison 74 avec nico
c'était comme ça ça crée un scandale et
il ya la dyscalculie c'est un mal que
peu connaissent regardant connaissent
pas le nom ça lui expliquer de quoi il
s'agit la dyscalculie c'est là la
possibilité de compter simplement les
gens qui sont perdues avaient avec les
chiffres avec l'arithmétique la plus
simple ça arrive assez mal non et vous
avez l'euromed einstein on the beach du
grand philip glass voilà alors que le
compère de steve reich ac 1-2 qui ont
inventé le versant new yorkais de la
musique répétitive terry riley s'était
plu autre versant californien en fait
donc ses musiques vous plus structurés
ou celle de peut-être de gris riley oui
or
[Musique]
tous les honneurs comme ça mais sans
effet c'est très envoûtant s'est brisé
sur le principe de la rythmique indienne
c'est à dire que c'est pas un temps
qu'on divise c'est un temps qu'on ajoute
alors il rajoute un temps au temps soit
5 et 10 2 fois 2 puis 3 x 3 mai que si
on suit on peut arriver à prévoir les là
on voit une fenêtre ification et vieux
alors qu'il était jaloux de bitche est
il très pétri d'ailleurs de musique
indienne musique orientale mais il avait
étudié à paris auprès de nadia boulanger
la musique c'est là qu'il a commencé
c'est très francophile elle a fait les
opéras sur des sur cocteau aussi mais
souvent dans sa musique et surtout de la
grande époque de la fin des années
soixante dix les paroles c'est soit un
deux trois quatre années d'efforts
soient do ré mi fa sol c'est à dire le
nom des nôtres qui sont en train de
chanter mais il en fait des trucs très
envoûtant il rêverait symphonie à partir
de news de david bowie il est assez
proche de gamal de rocker
alors dieu sait si une expression qui a
fait florès depuis quelques années c'est
faire son deuil
on aurait des problèmes à faire notre
deuil
et vous avez un remède pour ça c'est la
chanson breaking away days ah oui on
l'écouté
[Musique]
à
à bord c'est pour moi c'est de la belle
série mais dépend lacrymal mai
en
fait c'est une chanson que ray davies de
fauteur des kinks a écrite après
et que sa femme l'a quitté et donc il y
explique aulas tu m'as apporté toutes
ces journées que j'oublierai jamais
séjourné que je chéris chacune d'elles
chéri chaque heure chaque minute parce
que ça ne reviendra plus et moi je cette
chanson enfin pardon c'est très
personnel mais je les diffuser aux
funérailles d'un d'un ami avec qui je
partageais beaucoup de peu de goût pour
voilà pour ces musiques là et
c'est le moment où j'ai franchement je
vais éclater en sanglots je dis pas que
c'est ce que de souhaitable mais chacun
sur bouclerait fatigue c'est impossible
c'est possible
mais mais en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est qu'après avoir entendu cette
chanson quelque chose qui s'est délivré
en moins qui s'est libérée que s'est
ouvert qui s'est brisée et au fond j'ai
accepté la situation c'est à dire que
oui mais voilà ça reviendra plus j'ai vu
ça mais quelqu'un a eu je dirais le
génie et la tendresse de le dire et avec
cet art si délicat de la banalité kkr et
des risques c'est pour vous que l'équipe
chez le plus grand groupama pour moi
c'est le plus grand groupe de rock ou
monde oui enfin je veux dire les bleus
tous les temps de tous les temps de tous
les temps oui oui
ah oui oui pour moi disons que les
chansons les chansons classiques
immortel
écrite par les kings se peuvent
surpasser peuvent se briser certaines
des beatles et certaines des choses
certainement elles sont beaucoup moins
connu enfin pour moi c'est du niveau de
dylan voilà ces énoncés ray davies est
un génie
je n'ai jamais écouté deux peuples du
top 15
ans j'écoutais les mets moi c'était bon
première phase les doors led zep surtout
les aides qui est moins un des très
grands groupes est ce que la musique est
formidablement bien fait oui ces savants
et puis après je suivais cherifi talent
génération un peu punk non je suis
passée totalement new wave avant de
m'apercevoir que ce fait je préférais
peut-être les les premières choses que
j'avais appris
beaucoup de vivre ce qu'ils achètent et
votre livre qui ne s'attendent pas y
trouver du jazz vous ne connaissez le
jazz ni l'un ni l'autre
j'adore garner que j'ai cités et alex on
parle de dollars et puis je cite aussi
[Musique]
enfin bon c'est bon si vous en veut pas
et on revient juste après v vous allez
nous expliquer comment faire quand on
manque d'assurance vous avez plusieurs
trucs
[Musique]
michka assayas et benoît duteurtre sont
mes invités aujourd'hui avec alexandre
fillon il publie remède de musicaux et
ça vient de paraître chez buchet chastel
et comme remède au manque d'assurance
par exemple vous proposez et charges
trop
[Musique]
et je sais ça c'est
dit que au 20e siècle on sait pas
toujours en france on aurait peut-être
un peu moins bien mais ses poèmes
symphoniques zarathoustra cette façon
cette introduction a de façon
intentionnelle musique aussi puissante
avec juste un accord quasiment et un
grand crescendo très très lente faut
s'accepter d'ailleurs tellement repris
par le cinéma par la télévision c'était
musique générique du journal de la 5
et vous arrivez à la fin et jean claude
bourret
alors je sais pas s'il bourg est un art
à tous ce train est en tout cas c'est
une un poème symphonique de 40 minutes
génie c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé très
belle contre le manque d'assurance je
trouve ça c'est pas ça 10
ans et ça vous vous proposer autre chose
pete king des deep purple alors là sans
succès
[Musique]
ça s'est vu
après un long solo d'orgue et celle à
qui le morceau démarre vraiment à ce que
la cour ait une espèce de puissance
d'énergie moi j'étais très fin à
quatorze ans de deep purple j'avais été
ré tous leurs disques c'est à 14 ans
pour des fans nommé après ça semble
inquiétant oui mais disons en effet le
manque d'assurance et quand même une des
caractéristiques de cette est
particulièrement problématique
conditions de l'enfance à l'adolescence
et en effet on a l'impression n'a pas de
poils on est trop petit et on veut pas
vers ce qu'on veut on se sent écrasés
par les grands
on voudra mais on peut pas et c est donc
le hard rock vous donne cette impression
de puissance en exercice et ennemi on
l'est on les toise on porte des tenues
de gladiateurs détenus guerrière est
atterrant des des vikings on est des
super héros c'est ça le hardware est là
et j'avais furieux parce que j'avais un
surveillant qui disait à moi j'écoutais
en passant l'aspirateur
on peut donc pas du tout c'est une
musique fort bien et offre souvent le
maroc sait très bien construit au
contraire c'est très proche de certaines
musiques baroques c'est toujours très
bien construit dans les lignes et la
vraie solo d'orgue way qui est très
justement de la musique baroque
classique et tout d'un coup
alors
quel suspense
un musicien classique sont les groupes
de hard il ya un des groupes de l'époque
emerson lake and palmer qui avaient ce
virtuose des claviers qui étaient
différents sous types leurs données mais
pas céder ses rangs construit comme du
vivaldi un parfois ça j'en avais pas
pensé à rivel vidéo
je propose d'écouter quelques notes de
khon très belle chanson de brigitte
fontaine je suis conne ce ballon son
meilleur disque 1,5 probablement avec
d'avouer turboust voilà écouter tout est
formidable de dans un cône dit ça y est
on sait qu'on peut tous se reconnaître
oui
ces moments dans la vie où on dit bébé
tout foirer mais je suis vraiment le
dernier des derniers que je suis nul de
toute façon à chaque soir pour les
mauvaises décisions ce que les mauvais
choix il ya un moment où ça devient un
truc qui vous rend hilare c'est à dire
que lé va tellement loin on a réellement
l'impression c'est une vieille d'une
clocharde dans le métro qui se met à
éructer comme vienne punk là et on se
dit mais elle y va tellement à fond au
fond ça vous guérite où quoi au sens
ridicule audouy effectivement peut-être
que c'est pas si catastrophique que ça
puisqu'il faut écouter des ja c'est la
musique la musique est formidable et
musique de brigitte fontaine c'est
vraiment de la buzine cervelle turboust
ce que le parcours de dao qu'il a fait
c'est très réussi et vous dites vous
proposiez fernand belle vous jeu
alors il faut l'écouter quand même
penser à ce midi exactement
l'amour
jean a besoin corps jambes
toujours
il est loin le temps
dissous vie je suis en pouvoir adhésif
et opposeront donc aucun modèle peut
encore vous être d'une quelconque
secours ans en 2021 en chantant et ben
c'est là quand il dit à moi un homme
quoi
du en tout temps par lui défendu un
homme
qui déclarait ça n'a plus meur un an
un dur adresse adducteurs
de
l'opérette qui s'appelle le rosier
vallat bus ont été tirées de maupassant
et en fait c'est ça que j'adore faire un
zèle souvent c'est quand ils jouent des
rôles de méchants et en fait c'est un
billet de village et tout d'un coup se
transforme après avoir été élu à un
concours et devient cours toutes les
femmes devient débaucher absolue et va
plus peur de rien et devient donc un
homme comme il le chante de cette façon
et s'il se sent très très bon dans ses
rôles à contre-emploi faire la belle n'a
pu on le peut aussi
photo fa oui
alors quand on s'est fait quitter ce qui
est arrivé à tout le monde
proposez levis costello ah oui la
vengeance elvis costello
happy now
non c'est pas la bonne pioche est ce que
c'est une autre version qu'on oubliera
tout de suite
en revanche les alors la maison de la
musique donc on doit être enragé ben oui
c'est un cri devant lancer vraiment
c'est la mauvaise foi de l'amoureux
éconduit de que de toute façon je n'ai
jamais aimé toute façon je suis soulagé
et puis toute façon tu es forcément tu
vas trouver un connard et tu va le
rendre malheureux tu vas les pourrir la
vie tant mieux bon débarras et a donc
ciblé c'est à cri de mauvaise foi qui
vous soulage parce qu'elle vient on ira
vite accès à faire la même chose avec
shalom à bas voilà voilà vous savez que
vous avez tort c'est pas le problème
mais vous avez besoin d'avoir tort et
vous avez besoin de cet exutoire la haie
et costello et et et était admirable
dans l'expression des mauvaises pensées
des mauvais sentiments parlant de
mauvaises pensées i even printemps je
n'ai pas eu de calme
niven printemps qui était la femme sacha
guitry qu'il quittera pour pierre
fresnay et
even printemps qui chantait j'ai deux
amants et mais ça y est ça c'est très
français je pense que dans aucun autre
pays au monde une femme n'aurait pu
chanter j'ai deux amants et en faire un
tube g2 avancer beaucoup mieux car je
fais croire à chacun d'eux que l'autre
lb c'est sérieux s'étaient fait broncher
les monter les enchères entre les deux
et c'est une chanson totalement immoral
que vous pouvez faire sacha guitry et
j'ai mis ça dans les remèdes contre la
montre la culpabilité de l'adultère
parce qu'elle elle en fait une espèce de
système de vie quand elle est très
contente ils y apprendront que davantage
domaine des mauvaises pensées vous
connaissez le bruit qui courait sur
sacha guitry
rires oui c'est elle qui l'a fait que
oui
disposait pas
la face et l'échangent devant la tombe
où quand tu il lui dit quand tu seras
morte on dira enfin froide et répondra
en direct
un peu un peu similaire il faut dire que
tout ce qui est de l'ordre de l'amour du
sexe évidemment ça donnait beaucoup de
musique mais aussi beaucoup de deux mots
contre lesquels il faut lutter vous
proposez the perfect drug
nine inch nails c'est pour quand le
désir est irrépressible
c
c'est vraiment la chanson parfaite sur
l'obsession du désir sexuel
stern le moment où on se prépare on
attend ça a été différé vous êtes raté
c'est le moment où vous avez acheté le
champagne vous avez vous savez qu'elle
va porter si qu'elle va porter ça elle
va vous dire etc et vous êtes là elle
est large pas encore quoi et d'eau et là
ça fait monter la tension et ça marche
même dans l'autre sens tap le même fond
si elle vient pas il ya un truc que vous
avez vécu une transe quand même pas une
option donc c'est génial chez vous avez
écouté bien sûr de lui et non mais il
faut l'écouter en boucle
sacerdoce et puis à côté bien côté du
réacteur passé le sexy qui fait mal hein
y'a il ya aussi le remède à
l'impuissance et dieu sait si c'est ça
justement de leur défilé et
c'est c est en ville dit carrément barry
white
chine indique musique de la partition
c'est un jeu de mots un pc une musique
totalement langoureuse j'aime
passionnément barry white du plus grand
surtout la période effectivement des
années 75 80 il ya des morceaux arrangés
orchestrée d'une façon totalement
géniale avec jean paige et toute
l'équipe qui l'avait c'est vraiment un
déluge de violon de corps de sensualité
leur chef s'appelle nov ou limiter leur
test rat et surtout il a la manie de
pratiquer des rythmes langoureux mais
qu'on peut penser à ses proches du
rythme sexuelle d'ailleurs il n'en fait
pas en fait pas mystère et c'est vrai
que chip music dans le genre c'est
vraiment à chef-d'oeuvre de musique
d'arrangements de coeur de coop et c'est
une chose justement extatique et voilà
une musique oblige entendu sheet music
extérieur album très bien mais la
version juste avant c'est à dire 72 oui
là je pensais qu'après ça n'avait plus
d'intérêt annoncée pilotes elles sont
plus grands morceaux et je connais des
compositeurs de musique très sérieuse
qui sont arrivés à d'admiration devant
la beauté des orchestrations et l'a
remis à savoir
après la question qui se pose c'est
l'orgasme alors pour aller à leurs biens
là vous dites que c'est le mozart et pas
n'importe quel mozart le concerto numéro
15 oui mais il faudrait avoir le passage
précis je suis passé qu'on voit là oui
mais voilà on nouveau sinon ça marche
pas
on n'est pas loin la com
oui il construit il les thèmes se mêlent
il ya une espèce de progression et on va
y avoir un crescendo qui a va arriver au
tri et le tri c'est un peu l'orgasme
quoi vous allez voir cela il continue de
bâtir la progression
ça monte encore un peu
ça monte toujours
et là on va arriver à l'explosion
on
et voilà
c'est fini déjà voilà sociale et
il ya toujours la préparation est
l'apogée du binaire la fin à la fin mais
c'est vrai que généralement les musiques
sont là pour suggérer pour encourager
pas pour conclure
je pense qu'il y a des liens complexes
on va pas entrer dans leur antre très
plaisir sexuel et le plaisir musical
mais pas toujours mais
on peut lutter aussi contre l'addiction
sexuelle
vous avez des recommandations alors curé
pour harvey weinstein ue oui mais voilà
il aurait écouté sa vraie benchs taille
ne seraient pas en prison et
scan serait probablement président de la
république il fallait écouter mozart au
sein et c'est évidemment donc jéhovah
10,7 du commandeur et à des affaires et
cibler tous les to les obsédés là
ah le pauvre nos joies dans les vallées
à commencer par le catalogue de toutes
les conquêtes mais il est rattrapé par
le spectre de la mort est puni pour
toutes ces fautes c'est l'apothéose de
don giovanni donc c'est unique hautement
recommandable à sevran un peu de mal à
seurre
ce contre les hutus ce qui ajoute on
peur qu'un jour on leur reproche un viol
et des causes de
ce que ça peut arriver aussi quand on
est perdu
prononcez-vous michka assayas qui est
suggéré e-monsite ah ah ça c'est
magnifique à andrea l'agglo de
musiciens turinois
j'ai découvert assez il ya très peu de
temps écoutez ses
côtés
[Musique]
ce qui est très bon c'est ya cette voix
qui semblait même kong chine et c'est à
dire qu'on a voulu été rejoint dans un
placard et voyez la voix est très ténue
l'agencé romaine sita et il ya
parallèlement un sentiment cosim mais
comme sur la pochette du disque voilà
alors donc si ce sentiment d'être
complètement perry dur et au lieu de
susciter une angoisse métaphysique
cette chanson entraîne vers une forme de
sérénité et d'apaisement eux-mêmes
d'acceptation de sa propre disparition
et de sa propre insignifiance et je
trouve quelque chose de d'action
merveilleux parce que finalement la
musique vous savez c'est comme les
enfants qui jouent à la guerre sans se
tuer car ça ça vous fait évoquer les
choses le pire de l'existence les plus
horribles ayant une connaissance suffi
aux voix là est en fait vous vivez tout
les 10 que vous n'avez pas connu que je
ne connaîtrai jamais et c'est pour ça
que la musique est magique vous proposez
aussi grue mule haoues accès à une vraie
de quand on est perdus c'est encore
mieux quand on ne comprend même pas ce
que c'était un australien aborigènes qui
parlaient une langue que personne ne
connaissait sans une il est
malheureusement fait savoir
[Musique]
ah oui je vous avais du junior en fait
par quelle mouche de mal particulier
j'associe cette voie comme remède mais
en tout cas c'est une voix qui nous
délivre de 2,2 to qui vous élève parce
que tout de même la musique
souvent enfin elle est là pour
vous empêcher de vous noyer et
et quand vous écoutez ça franchement
vous surnager vous survivez à tous vas
voir c'est l'expérience que j'ai que
j'ai dans les pires malheurs j'écoute
seulement deux voix et ça me sam élèves
il y en a une à lormes wakim élèves ceux
que vous citez également aussi c'est la
chanson qu'est ce que t'es beau oui ça
l'est catherine et la radio al ani alors
pourquoi ne vous l'avez choisi celle ci
est plutôt un peu parce que j'ai voulu
de promettre en tête
tous
[Musique]
font
la consolation
que peuvent trouver ce qu'ils ne savent
pas qui ne se trouve jamais à la hauteur
de ce qu'ils vivent et qui pense que de
toute façon tout va foirer et ils
entendent saisie au fond il ya un
bonheur pour les gens médiocres
c'est un grand coup
quand on est
paralysé
dans l'impossibilité de bouger je crois
que c'est vous benoît duteurtre qui
recommandait james bond mais qui peuvent
être lues james spécialement début des
années 70 la période qui est ses
morceaux y moi ce que j'adore chez james
wan c'est qu'il a mis au point une
espèce de mécanique assez épuré mais
d'une efficacité
nawel redoutable avec les deux guitares
rythmiques la masse la voix qui éructe
selon mme sue les quelques intéressantes
que et c'est souvent d'une simplicité
bah oui mais en même temps d'une
puissance extraordinaire a dit qu'il
nous fait tout de suite vous voudrez ces
français avouent des rochers à danser
d'ailleurs les dj en savent quelque
chose il ya un temps mort dans une boîte
de nuit servette certains j'ai besoin de
bien choisir de suite c'est vraiment le
le dieu du rythme pour moi dans la
deuxième moitié du xxème siècle avait
aucun raison ccc les purs oui c'est
vraiment c'est triste et c'est d'un
allié de violeurs s'est mêlant les
musiciens qu'il avait été exceptionnel
enfin le tromboniste fred wesley hosie
maceo parker enfin bon c'est et c'est
vrai que ce serait fou de guitare et
fait avancer les morceaux à lui tout
seul saccades et
d'une subtilité extraordinaire c'est
mécanique parfaite
l'usr occupe tible
s'il ya une chanson lugubre où il fait
par un type d'ailleurs qui est mort à 26
ans nick drake à ouidah et qui a fait un
seul disque je crois en tout cas c'est
après sa mort que oui
il ya cette chanson riverman qui sait
jouer des chansons les plus tristes y
aller elle est désespérante mais hélas
est-ce qu'on peut écouter un peu elle
arrive quand même il faudra soit de quoi
ah ben
oui eh ben c'est le spleen du dimanche
soir -
il ya quelque chose c'est vraiment le
moment en ce moment on vit ça enfin vers
cinq heures du soir interclubs
lumière hier soir c'est ça fait deux ans
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment il n'y a
plus de lumière il ya la brûle tout le
monde et enfin les lumières s'allument
un peu partout et puis là vous êtes
désespérés parce que c'est dimanche soir
vous avez rien faire vous avez gâché
votre journée vous avez voulu voir un
film ce n'est pas bon on ne sait pas
quoi vous être disputé et tout cela vous
écoutez ça et vous dites mais enfin la
vie est merveilleuse fête fait suivant
fous moi c'est yahia qui aie aie aie aie
il ya la nature ya les armes via les
lacs il ya les montagnes enfin il ya
cette espèce d'estibeaux je suis pas de
quoi au juste il par l'homme du fleuve
qui va offrir un secret qui est cet
homme du fleuve des personnages de
contes fantastiques
on ne sait pas si c'est un avantage des
chansons anglo-saxonnes ils sont pas
tenues cette rigueur intellectuelle
demander pourquoi j'aimais pas en
majorité la chanson française et ma
réponse je les trouvais à cette heure
c'est que toujours les souvent trop
souvent mais il ya des exceptions
merveilleuse trop souvent les auteurs
français veulent expliquer bah oui c'est
comme comme comme nous disaient nos bons
professeurs quand l'auteur a voulu dire
que c'est qu'il est mauvaise et qu'il a
raté son coup mais c'est que ces
littératures forte que la chance au foot
pour eux expliquait du meulage d'image
c'est des images c'est gratuit ça n'a
pas forcément de sens c'est là c'est la
beauté du télescopage des images où il a
il ya encore mieux il ya la musique
classique où l'on n'est pas en bas à
senna les paroles et et contre leurs
envies de suicide
duteurtre ou deep ravel daphnis et chloé
lever du jour surtout le mouvement final
de daphni sac doré c'est une espèce
d'enchantement pura c'est tellement beau
cette grande phrase qui s'élève dans
leur pièce radieuse parce que ravel
c'est une contraire du romantisme et
musique l'extase de la contemplation et
se bat les daphnies c'est peu c'est
peut-être le chef-d'oeuvre de la musique
symphonique du début du 20e siècle et
donc ça finit par ce grand ensemble avec
choeur et orchestre qui moi me me rend
heureux me réconforte me donne envie de
vivre
ici vous êtes encore là c'est
symbolique c'est pas vraiment mêlant
nous ont dit que c'est sensuel
ccc habiter c'est vibrant etc mais c'est
ça l'essentiel
vous étiez plutôt des équipes commencent
à pleuvoir écoutiez vendent mojito et
abonnements isound et qui pleuvaient les
gens de notre génération écoutez c'est
vrai parce qu'il pleut tout le temps en
irlande
linden
kembs en français
[Musique]
même sa voix et pluvieux
c'est une des plus belles voix au monde
c'est un peu le otis redding irlandais
enfin pour moi s'il ya ce mélange des
cris de désespoir et d'extase percer les
deux vont la plus belle musique est
celle qui convoque ses deux c2 opposé à
richard c
il faut l'écouter
vous continuer d'en écouter d'autres
pour conjurer la malchance the smiths à
willy's let me get oui voilà ça j'adore
cette série
c8000 1,85 à une durée de vie éphémère
même si son chanteur a fait une carrière
très longue après banc d'essai mais
oui
ces derniers beaucoup d'autodérision
dans les serres c'est vraiment c'est
marrant parce que je reviens toujours à
ce qu'il ait permis une fois rade et
c'est vrai c'est vrai
je veux dire que oui mais en même temps
ils ont ils en tirent une sorte de deux
sourires de sourire où il ya beaucoup de
tendresse et c'est vraiment ils disent
bon bah voilà pour une fois peut-être
que je pourrai avoir de la chance s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît mon dieu
laissez-moi obtenir une fois juste une
fois ce que je ce dont j'ai envie et au
fond c'est un peu le spleen de
l'adolescente
le voilà la personne aimée qui vous
échappe lalala le métier qu'on voudrait
faire qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
l'équivalent avoue benoît duteurtre
c'est l'ouverture de l'épi voleuse
oui mais aussi 10 et le pharmacien en
chef lui c'est vraiment de caution de
s'y impliquer toute sa vie à faire ça et
les effectivement les ouvertures des
opérateurs notamment celle de la pie
voleuse avec ses petits personnages
musicaux animés qui dans ce qu'ils
décident qui se répondent et c'est assez
extraordinaire parce qu'on est en plein
siècle romantique dans que la grande
musique va plutôt vers l'émotion la
tension est aussi lui tint espèces
d'enchanteur il ne sera tout s'est réglé
un succès absolument da reggae rock sans
dire s'il convient dans le plus célèbre
d'europe et il se plaît à enchanter à
sourire en musique ce qui n'est pas si
fréquent un génie du sourire en musique
et en même temps il est tellement dans
un recherche de la jouissance qu'une
fois qu'il aura connu les plus grands
succès de la musique il arrête la
musique pour se consacrer à la cuisine
et réception de ces avis dans son hôtel
particulier parisien bien sûr la plus
grande star du rock star il a fuit dans
les ordres a cédé l'habit liste à la fin
juillet non c'était des personnages
véritablement tragique
c'était pas contre la procrastination
d'ailleurs vous conseiller la santa
cecilia ah oui ça c'est le boulot un
paquet
travail oui là c'est plutôt léger là
pour une fois je vais pas vous faire le
couple est la vie est un désastre c'est
non non pas du tout c'est vous savez
vous êtes vous avez parents du travail
attend vos collaborateurs sur vous en
veux le haut
vous morfondez parce que parce que vous
vous dites j'ai travaillé toute mon
équipe etc et puis tout à coup un modèle
cette voix qui vous dit mais pourquoi
vous en faire pour travailler pourquoi
vous tout ça va s'arranger toute façon
des retombées sur vos pieds la terre va
continuer de tourner tout ça n'est pas
si grave et c'est extrêmement joyeux
c'est un groupe qui a été fondée par des
chicanos sauvadet des émigrés des
immigrés mexicains à los angeles s'est
elle a une voix géniale elle s'appelle
cl jeu plus on l'appelle la mar y sol
qui paradoxe de ce livre c'est quand
pour lutter contre le froid ne veut de
l'époque je pense conseil oui d'écouté
joao gilberto jusque là rien de très
normal c'est père de la bossa nova la
musique que l'europe probablement que
c'est le plus exporté à travers le monde
au 20e siècle après midi comme le saxon
mais vous choisissez swann d'or foule
c'est à dire une chanson de george
gershwin interprété par joao gilberto
alors qu'il a fait tellement de facteurs
extraordinaires c'est un bon et c'est
dans un disque extraordinaire on a été
arrangé par un grand arrangeur allemands
de chez ninon avec les cordes et cetera
jo de germann exactement voilà et c'est
tout les premiers 10 2
de l'est se sont tus carlos slim sont à
ce disque est d'une couleur d'une
sensualité qui moi me touche encore plus
que dans le côté un peu plus dépouillé
de
gilberto avec sa guitare et la façon
dont il revisite tous ces morceaux avec
une chaleur dans la voix et dans les
couleurs et dans l'expression je trouve
ça irrésistible tout cet album est une
merveille du début à la fin et puis
cette chanson c'est celle qui ouvre
l'album et chacune est merveilleuse ans
que j'ai liberto est quand même meilleur
dans les chansons brésiliennes qui
maintenant il est très très monde en
titre thunder foule ça devient une
chanson dédiée devient du gilberto quand
il la chante dans ce dans ce disque pour
lutter contre le froid et dieu sait si
ces chansons s'impose voilà on va
s'arrêter là l'émission est terminée
merci tous les deux d'avoir participé
d'y avoir participé
et évidemment on a on n'a pas vu le
dixième
tous que ce que vous proposez pour pour
survivre dans ce livre votre pharmacopée
bien plus riche que ça évidemment merci
tous les deux merci de nous avoir suivis
les remèdes musicos est paru aux
éditions buchet chastel
bon noël on se retrouve à la rentrée
passée de très bonnes fêtes
[Musique]